Guten Tag. Ich bin die die Erste in der Stadt und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, sicher. Klar, Hauptsache, ich kriege Hilfe.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz. Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie mir Fragen, ja am Ende des Gesprächs können Sie Ihre Fragen stellen.
Okay.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Besonderheit erzählen, möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Werner Haas.
Werner ist ein Männername, W-E-R-N-E-R.
Ja, Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachname befinden?
Ja, H-A-S.
Herr Haas, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 49.
49. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 19.04.73.
Wie groß sind Sie? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 185 und ich wiege 91 kg.
Ein bisschen wie?
Ja, ich weiß.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Söhne habe ich.
Und was sind Sie von der Ruh?
Ich bin Ingenieur.
In welchem Bereich?
Maschinenbau.
Und wo wohnen Sie? Wie ist Ihre Apfeladresse?
Ja, die ist Süderstraße 15 in Rheine.
Ich weiß keinen Ort in der Nähe von Dessau-Roschlau.
Und bei wem sind Sie in Hausärztincherbehandlung?
Ah, wenn man Hausarzt ist.
Das ist der Dr. Müller.
Ich kenne noch nicht diese Kollege.
Ja, ich bin neu hier.
Der ist in der Felsenstraße.
Dr. Müller ist in der Felsenstraße.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe solche unglaublichen Rückenschmerzen.
Ich habe beide Schmerzen.
Ich habe diese Schmerzen im unteren Rücken.
Ich kann mich kaum noch rühren.
Angefangen hat es, ich habe im Garten gearbeitet.
Dann habe ich einen Schwerenblumentopf an die Seite geschoben.
Dann habe ich einen Schuss reinbekommen.
Und diese Schmerzen sind jetzt wirklich so, dass ich mich kaum rühren kann.
Das geht auch ins ganze Bein rein.
Herr Haas, wie sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalapon 1 bis 10?
Wenn ein sehr leichter Schmerz ist, dann sind es 10.
Ein unerzwecklicher Schmerz.
Da sind die Schmerzen bestimmt bei 8.
Das tut unsinnig weh.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis Ende des Geschäbtes aushalten?
Ja, ich versuche halt eine Hüteposition einzunehmen.
Und ich habe das ja schon seit gestern.
Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzstabete geben?
Ich habe ja schon was genommen. Das hat aber nicht viel geholfen.
Insofern lassen Sie uns lieber weitermachen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Erst am Abend war das oder spät am Nachmittag.
Ist es dann Abend?
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal die ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, Röntenschmerzen habe ich schon immer mal wieder, wenn ich mich belaste.
Also was, was ich so bei der Gartenarbeit oder wenn ich mal jemandem helfe beim Umziehen oder sowas.
Ja, dann...
Also die Schmerzen treten nur bei Belastung?
Ja, ja, dann habe ich schon mal Röntenschmerzen.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie drückend oder stechend?
Also ich würde schon sagen, das ist stechend.
Stechend und so einschließend.
Und Strahlen und Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Ja, das ganze rechte Bein runter zieht das bis in die kleine Zährein.
Und Geräte haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie haben, manche Medikamente eingehauen haben?
Ja, ähm...
Was für Medikamente haben Sie...
Ja, ich habe... was habe ich denn genommen?
Wie hoch Profen hatte ich zu Hause?
Und da habe ich zwei Stück genommen, aber das hat irgendwie nicht viel gebracht.
Wie hoch Profen? 600 Milligramm?
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber das habt Ihnen nicht geholt?
Nee, das hat mich viel gebracht, nein.
Und...
Ich...
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen liegen?
Sind die Schmerzen lagerungsabhängig?
Ja, also ich habe versucht, heute Nacht mich halt hinzulegen.
Wenn man dann erstmal liegt, dann geht es ungefähr, ja.
Aber sobald man die Position auch nur ein bisschen verändern will,
hat man das Gefühl, man braucht einen Kran, ja.
Also es ist ganz schwer, sich aus eigener Kraft zu bewegen.
Es ist also sehr schmerzhaft.
Und...
Sind die Schmerzen eher mordend oder tagüber?
Nein, die habe ich jetzt den ganzen Tag schon.
Also seit gestern Abend habe ich die Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Epipa, Schütelbrot oder Nachweiß?
Nein, nein, nein.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stürzern?
Hm...
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Ein bisschen Blähungen habe ich, aber ja.
Also wenn ich so rohe Lebensmittel esse, dann kriege ich schnell Blähungen.
Aber richtig Schulgangprobleme habe ich nicht.
Aber heute Nacht war ich froh, dass ich nicht zwischendurch auf die Toilette musste.
Ich hätte mich kaum rühren können.
Heute konnten Sie nicht auf die Toilette gehen.
Ich musste zum Glück nicht in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen.
Das wäre so schmerzhaft gewesen, nochmal aufzustehen, ja.
Ja, und haben Sie...
haben Sie Krippen in Ihrem Bein, in Ihrem rechten Bein?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Das geht bis zu den Zehen und so außen am rechten Bein.
Das fühlt sich so ein bisschen taub an.
Und haben Sie Muskelschweiche in Ihrem Bein?
Ja, also ich denke, ich kann mich überhaupt...
Kraftlosigkeit. Leiden Sie Unterkraftlosigkeit?
Das merke ich jetzt nicht so.
Ich merke halt, dass ich mich generell ganz schlecht bewegen kann, ja.
Weil ich kann mich ja kaum rühren mit diesem Schmerzen dann.
Und ist Ihnen übelt?
Nee, so ist es nun auch wieder nicht.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert?
Nee, der ist immer gut.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit stark abgeholt?
Nee, das ist schon ziemlich stabil.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen herrhasst?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich bin schon seit der Kindheit Diabetika.
Und hab auch eine Insulin-Kurse.
Und seit wann haben Sie zu Kaka Diabetika?
Ja, da war ich so zehn ungefähr, als das festgestellt wurde.
Seit zehn Jahren oder mit zehn?
Mit zehn Jahren. Ich war ein Kind. Also als Kind habe ich doch gar.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch.
Und die Blutfettwerte, das hat man auch festgestellt.
Die sind auch ein bisschen zu hoch.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, wie gesagt, die Insulin-Kumper habe ich, dann habe ich Mikardis Plus.
In welcher Beziehung nehmen Sie?
40 zu 12,5, dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch Atorvastatin.
Dann nehme ich eine abends.
Atorvastatin, eine abends.
Ja, Atorvastatin nehme ich abends eine.
In welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Das ist Atorvastatin zehn.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie noch irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme noch Thebonin 120.
Das ist...
Klonzensebite wieder hoch?
Thebonin 120, das ist ein Medikament gegen Tinnitus.
Wogegen nehmen Sie?
Tinnitus.
Und ich habe vor anderthalb Jahren einen Hörsturz gehabt.
Und seit her habe ich dieses permanente Ohr geräuscht.
Das ist ganz unangenehm.
Okay, reagieren Sie auch irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja.
Amoxicillin habe ich mal mit ordentlich Ausschlag reagiert.
Und das darf ich nicht haben.
Und wenn die Haselnusse blühen, wenn da die Polen fliegen,
dann geht es mir auch nicht gut.
Dann habe ich Schnupfen und so verquollene Augen.
Und so früh im Frühjahr habe ich damit Probleme.
Frühblühen.
Ja, also Haselnuspolen.
Haselnuspolen.
Und haben Sie welche Unerzeltfähigkeit?
Wie gesagt, Sie hatten ja nach Verdauungsproblemen gefragt.
Wenn ich rohe Lebensmittel esse, ja, also rohes Gemüse oder rohes Obst,
dann kriege ich sehr schnell, also heftige Blähungen.
Da muss ich immer ein bisschen gucken.
Welche ist es?
Ich habe nicht dann Akustik.
Nicht gekochtes Gemüse oder Obst.
Also rohes Gemüse.
Okay.
Und sind Sie gegen Corona-Büro oder Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich bin gegen alles geimpft und habe auch drei Corona-Infungen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und rauchen Sie?
Ja, so rauchen kann man das eigentlich nicht nennen.
Ich rauche immer nur so bei der Arbeit so zwei, drei Zigaretten am Tag.
Beide, drei Zigaretten am Tag.
Das kann man eigentlich nicht als Rauch und Zählen, ne?
Das ist wirklich nur ganz wie ...
Viel, aber es wäre besser, wenn Sie total aufhören würden.
Ach ja, aber das ist so gesellig, ne?
Und es macht eine Pause zwischendurch, ja.
Und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ach ja, das habe ich angefangen mit der Arbeitsstelle da.
Ja, das sind so 15 Jahre jetzt.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, abends trinke ich schon eigentlich regelmäßig ein Glas Wein, ja.
Was trinken Sie?
Wein trinke ich gerne abends.
Im Sommer weiß Wein, im Winter auch malen Rotwein.
Wie viel Glas?
Ein Glas am Abend.
Und das ist eine Routinefrage.
Ich muss auch diese Frage stellen.
Herr Hart, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, also jetzt heute nicht mehr.
In meiner Jugend, ja, da habe ich mal Marihuana probiert.
Und ja, also Paar Joins geraucht, aber auch nicht wirklich viel.
Aber heute spielt das keine Rolle mehr.
Zum Glück.
Und gibt es in Ihrer Familie Erkrankungen, ja, wichtige Erkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich sind wir alle ganz gesund.
Mein Vater hat ein bisschen Hüftprobleme,
aber wie sonst sind eigentlich alle gesund.
Herr Gersund, wo seid ihr?
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben drei Döne.
Zwei.
Zwei Döne sind gesund.
Die sind gesund, ja.
Der eine hat so ein bisschen Probleme, der ist so, der hat so Nachzügler,
der ist noch ziemlich klein und der hat ein bisschen Probleme
mit dem Sprechen, der stottert ein bisschen.
Er stottert, der hat so ein Sprachfehler,
dass er manchmal so die Worteinfänge nicht rausbekommt.
Und leben Sie mit Ihrer Brau?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Und leben Sie in einer Wohnung oder in einem Haus?
In einem Einfamilienhaus.
Herr Gersund, drei Wünsche wie Sport?
Nein, neben der Arbeit ist es so schwer.
Also außer Garfenerarbeit und ein bisschen Fahrradfahren,
mache ich eigentlich nicht viel Sport.
Ich habe alle meine Sichtgepräge gestellt.
Herr Haas, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt ja eigentlich so viel erzählt.
Ich möchte jetzt eigentlich nur noch wissen,
was damit denn jetzt los ist, ob man da irgendwas gegen tun kann.
Und ja, das, was eben auch nicht wiederkommt,
das wäre mir ja wichtig.
Herr Haas, als erste haben wir immer drei Wünsche,
um eine richtige Diagnose stellen zu können.
Zuerst Anemnesigespräch, dann körperliche Untersuchung
und schließlich operative Diagnostik.
Wir haben ja nur eine Anemnesigespräch durchgeführt.
Und ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen
und bei Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Ich werde Ihre Röntgenuntersuchung veranlassen.
Was kann man bei der Röntgenuntersuchung feststellen?
Wenn es einen Knogenbruch gibt, können wir feststellen.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz im Wartezimmer.
Und ich werde Sie wieder aufrufen.
Ja, das ist okay.
Ich werde mit meiner Obererstin sprechen, wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Okay, gut.
Ich sehe Sie mal langsam rüber ins Zimmer.
Dr. Gönes, möchten Sie noch etwas wissen?
Nein, habe ich keine Frage.
Keine weiteren Frage.
Das spricht für Vollständigkeit.
Welche Tee können Sie jetzt?
Ich trinke Pfefferminze aus dem Garten.
Also so frische Blätter.
Schmeckt sehr gut.
Sonst wächst nicht viel in meinem Garten, was man essen kann.
Aber Pfefferminze wächst.
Ein Fotoschicken.
Von diesem Glas?
Ja, es sieht immer ein bisschen aus,
dass es noch ein Frosch drin wohnen könnte.
Ich zeige Ihnen das mal.
Es könnte auch noch ein Goldschisch mit drin sein.
Oder ein Frosch.
Aber es sind nur grüne Blätter.
Es ist ein sehr grünes Wasser.
Ich habe das lange nicht gemacht.
Aber als es zu heiß wurde,
ist mir das eingefallen, dass das Zeug da wächst.
Und dass man da sehr gut Tee kochen kann.
Normalerweise trinke ich Tag und Nacht schwarzen Tee.
Aber der macht natürlich auch noch mal warm.
Mit Schuka oder auch nicht Schuka?
Nein.
Ohne Zucker.
Aber ich mache hier nicht so stark wie die türkischen Leute.
Mein Tee zieht nur ganz kurz.
Dann ist der überhaupt nicht bitter.
Dann braucht man auch keinen Zucker.
Danke.
Nur dann?
Frau Oberles, ich möchte ...
Ich möchte ...
einen neuen ...
einen neuen Bericht ...
Wie viel?
Wen haben Sie denn aufgenommen oder gesehen?
Herr Beharr,
einen neuen
und einen guten ...
Nein.
Einem allgemeinen Zustand.
Und ...
einen ...
einen püren, ernährenen Zustand.
Er war zur Ortzeit
Person und Situation vollorientiert.
Und ...
er stellte sich ...
bestehende in Rechte
aus Australien auf einer Schmerzkala
bei Achtligende ...
bei Achtligende
bei Achtligende Lumballien
vor
unter Ausnahme ...
... er stellte sich ...
keine Besetzung.
Und ...
die Schmerzen
seien ...
seien stecken
und einsiehen
...
der Patient berichten von Bewegung,
Anschränkung
und ...
er klackte
über ...
er klackte über
Parisie im Rechten
Bein.
Parisie oder Parisie?
Parisie.
Parisie ist auch Lähmung.
Parisie ist ...
Gefühlsstörung.
Parisie.
Die Allergie äußere sich als Hauptauslag.
Er habe Hazelniskolen-Allergie und er habe Unverträglichkeit gegen nicht gestopftes Gemüse.
Ich habe ein Glas Wein und Drogenabufel als Jugendlicher.
Er hat Drogen konsumiert.
Ich habe ein Marihuana-Projekt.
In der Familienanamnese gab sich ein Koksalgie beim Vater.
Die Anamnestische Angaben deuten am ehesten Bandscheibenvorfall hin.
Was wäre noch differentialdiagnostisch möglich?
An was müssen wir auch denken im schlechtesten Fall?
rechtesten Fall? Ja, wenn er da Frakturzeichen hat, wo kann die her kommen? Wurst, Wurst,
Wurst, Ach so, ja, das ist eine Möglichkeit, Osteoporose, oder aber, wenn da was metastasiert
in die Wirbelsäule. Wurzereizung geht auch, ja. Ja, aber das war jetzt mein Gedanke, also hier
ist angegeben Metastasierung. Ja, Metastasiv, Metastasiv, Katzinau, auch, genau, auch die
Wurst, die ist jetzt in die Schlage-Variante. Und gut, und was machen Sie denn jetzt mit dem
Patienten diagnostisch? Ja, der Patient wurde stationär aufgenommen, ein Venöselzugang wurde
geleckt, körperliche Untersuchung wurde durchgeführt. Ja, was haben Sie da, also worauf haben Sie
denn das geachtet bei der körperlichen Untersuchung? Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, Homa,
nicht Homa, Taya, Homa ist für Obose. Lasek, Taischen, Lasek und Ternik, ja, Lasek und Ternik,
ja, genau. Lasek und Ternik, Taischen sind wichtig für diese Patienten. Ja, und was gucken Sie
noch, also wenn Sie den Patienten körperlich untersuchen, was machen Sie mit den Händen? Klopfschmerz,
Klopfschmerz oder Druckschmerz über der Vierbesäule? Klopfschmerz, also wenn Sie klopfen, also
ausdrücken oder auf Druck, ob der da eine Schmerzreaktion zeigt. Gut, was machen Sie denn im Labor?
Ich werde, ja, Brutprobe, Brutprobe, Brutprobe, Brutprobe, Brutprobe, Brutbit, Brutbit, Brutberberber,
Ja, genau. Was machen Sie, was machen Sie apparativ? Zuerst muss eine Röntgenuntersuchung
rüff geführt werden. Was wird geräumt?
Ja, wir müssen bewerfen, ob es ein Knochenbrut, ja, eine Fraktur gibt.
Und wenn Sie wissen wollen, ob der wirklich einen Bandscheibenvorfall hat, was machen Sie dann?
Sollte die Verdassungsmote auch Bandscheibenvorfall bestätigen.
Wie kriegen Sie das raus? Sehen Sie den Bandscheibenvorfall im Röntgen?
Nein, MRT, MRT, operative Röntgenuntersuchung.
Ja, genau. Also erst das Röntgen und dann das MRT von der Röntgenuntersuchung.
Ja, genau. Ja, genau.
Ja, können wir die GWB besser beurteilen.
Mhm, genau.
MRT. Und sollte sich die Verdassungsmote auch Bandscheibenvorfall bestätigen.
Was wären die konservativen Maßnahmen?
Analympic, Analympic, Antisphagemolipik, Muskelrelaxanz.
Ja, und was würde man den Patienten auch noch?
Physiotherapie, Physiotherapie, Krankengymastik.
Frankengymastik.
Genau.
Und eingeleitet werden.
Ja, und was wäre dann so ein Zwischending zwischen den reinen konservativen Maßnahmen
und der OP, was könnte man da noch machen?
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob das auf dem aktuellen Stand ist.
Vielleicht haben wir ein Orthopäden im Plenum, der uns sagt, was richtig ist.
Ich habe hier noch zwei Sachen stehen, die, das eine wäre eine paravertebrale Blockade
unter CT-Kontrolle, dass man also da praktisch die Nerven lahmlicht
oder Cortisol-Einspritzung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das tatsächlich heute alles noch so macht.
Ja, ja.
Das ist vielleicht einer der Kolleginnen dazu, mehrere Sachen sagen.
Weißt irgendjemand was dazu?
Ne, also auch gut.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt hatten die Prüfer hier noch zwei Fragen.
Nämlich, welcher Nerv ist betroffen, nachdem wir die Schmerzen beschreibt?
Nervus.
Ja, genau.
Das ist der Klassiker.
Der Klassiker.
Mein Ischias.
Oh, ja.
Also, Ischias Nerv mit der Ausstrahlung, das ganze Bein runter
und in die Gesäßbacke rein.
Genau.
Und der Kampfer, der tatsächlich der sehr vernünftige Hinweis,
als ich gefragt habe nach der Metastasierung, hat jemand gleich gesagt,
er hat doch gar keine Besen-Gematik.
Stimmt natürlich, hat er wirklich nicht.
Ist tatsächlich hier nur auf dem Zelt gewesen?
Ja.
Ja, aber die Prüfer haben tatsächlich gefragt,
wenn es tatsächlich eine Metastasierung wäre,
wo würde man den Primarius suchen?
Das ist der Klassiker.
Wenn es eine Metastasierung wäre,
wo würde man den Primarius suchen?
Wermetastasiert in die Wirbelsäule.
Ein Klassiker wissen Sie ganz bestimmt.
Ich versuche mich nicht.
Ein Klassiker, wissen Sie ganz sicher.
Prostata.
Ja, ja.
Also, bei Frauen, bei Strips geht, glaube ich,
sehr gerne in die Wirbelsäule
Und bei Männern eben in der Prostatakarsinum, da ist das recht häufig.
Und ansonsten ist hier noch die Lunge genannt gewesen.
Aber ja, das sind ja auch alles eher Fachfragen als Sprachfragen.
Das ist ja blöd.
Aber die Prüfer haben das halt hier in diesem speziellen Fall gefragt.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Fall aus Mainz oder München.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, Frau Dr. Afti, dann halten Sie mich über den Herrn Haas auf dem Laufenden, wie es ihm weitergeht.
Und dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über den.
Ja? Okay.
Gut.
Aha, da kam gerade der Hinweis, es ist ein Münchner Fall.
Ja.
Ja, bei uns auch häufig.
Ja, in diesem Fall häufig bei uns auch.
Kommt bei Ihnen auch da, das ist ja wunderbar.
Ja, dann habe ich ja mal den richtigen aus dem Hut gezaubert.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut.
Ja, wie geht es Ihnen?
Haben Sie sich gefühlt im Gespräch?
Ja, besser.
Jeder Tag besser.
Ja, am Anfang konnte ich sogar die Fragen nicht stellen.
Ja, zum Beispiel last month.
Aber jeden Tag besser.
Ja, also ich fand bei den Fragen waren sie sehr souverän.
Ja, im Arzt-Patienten-Gespräch waren sie sehr souverän und das war auch alles klar und eindeutig.
Nachher in dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch waren sie so ein bisschen verunsichert und vielleicht
habe ich auch ein bisschen zu viel gefragt.
Ja, aber ich denke mal, Sie haben ja noch ein bisschen Zeit und Sie werden noch viele
Anamiesen hören.
Ja, das ist schon beide zu lange.